halloween events they are back all
around the valley from haunted houses
like the asylum hotel phil or fear over
at meadows mall opportunity village has
their halloween something for everyone
though and that includes bianca holman
who is live at downtown summerlin with
one of the really cool family friendly
options hey bianca
hey good morning nate so again i know
parents are always looking for something
that is mildly scary right that our kids
can handle in downtown summerlin their
parade of mischief is one of those
things so it's returned this year
so we are so excited about that haley
mason here to join us to tell us more
what can people look forward to it's
been a while since we've had the parade
exactly we are so thrilled to bring it
back so every friday and saturday at 7
pm at downtown summerlin we'll have a
parade of mischief and then we'll have
festive characters and props and things
like that so come on down get your spot
on the street and enjoy the parade yeah
so much to look forward to and it's free
it's free the kids can get candy they
see a show and also tell us what's
happening halloween weekend so the 28th
through the 31st dance dynamics will be
doing a production of the adams family
so you can even enjoy the parade that
weekend and then go check that
production out on milan that is so great
and again these times friday and
saturday free to the families but also
you know it's so good to see that the
people who are involved in these shows
are from the community that's correct we
work with best agency and we cast all
local kids for the all both the holiday
and the halloween parade and we are just
thrilled because we able to you know
show off the vegas talent of the local
kids yeah so this is so great again it's
great to know that from whether you want
to visit a haunted house and really get
scared out of your mind or some kind of
escape room or something like that or
you need something a little bit more
family friendly like opportunities
village halloween events or coming down
here to downtown summerlin and the
parade of mischief all great things
happening across the valley and of
course we'll definitely have all this
information listed on our website
8newsnow.com bianca holman live local
now